Michael here. Hopefully you know me from
other office hours. I'm a core
maintainer on the BLM project. I work on
a lot of things there and yeah, excited
to tell you what's new in VLM in the
past two weeks. Rob.
Hey
>> everyone, I'm Rob. I'm one of the
co-leads of VLM and of LMD. Nice nice to
be on.
>> I'm Charles. I'm one of the LM
compressor maintainers.
>> Hi everyone. I'm I'm Brian. I'm a
maintainer on LM compressor as well
along with Charles.
>> Great. Yeah. So, as as we mentioned,
we're going to cover what's new over the
past two weeks since the last office
hours. We have our special topics and
lightning talk for today. In terms of
VLM project updates, we have a good
number of model releases, blogs, and
some yeah, training and social media fun
that we'll go over in addition to the
latest VLM0.24 release. So without
further ado, let's get into it. One
quick note is we do have already a
pretty packed future list of office hour
sessions. So we have Matish from Prime
RL will be giving a a talk on his RL at
one trillion parameter scale using Prime
RL and VLM in two weeks. Then we have a
Moon Cake VLM LMD deep dive from Greg
and and K there. and then we'll do a
guide LLM deep dive and what's going on
in the latest release there. To get into
VLM, if you're not already familiar,
it's the open source standard for
inference serving of large language
models. It's become that because it's of
course a permissible open- source Apache
2.0 licensed project on GitHub. It's
part of the PyTorch Foundation which is
ultimately part of the Linux Foundation.
Governance is is is great. It has
support from dozens of major companies,
academic institutions. Of course, it was
originally started at UC Berkeley from
the page tension paper and over the past
three or so years has grown into a huge
project where we have over 85,000 GitHub
stars, thousands of PRs submitted every
month that we try to merge in as many as
possible. It's deployed on over 20
million GPU hours every day from the
metrics we at least have. So, it's much
more in aggregate. I checked that
recently. It's a pretty insane number to
think about. We have a developer Slack
with over 15,000 members. So, if you're
interested in active development or
understanding what's going on in the
various special interest groups we have,
it's a great place to be. We also
heavily prioritize usability. So, of of
course, when a new model comes out,
particularly a state-of-the-art model
day by day, week by week, we want to
make sure you can run that in VLM on the
various hardware that you want to run
on. more than just Nvidia, but getting
great performance there, but also on
AMD, Google TPUs, Huawei Ascend, all
sorts of hardware accelerators built al
into VLM ultimately as the software
abstraction between how to run the
hundreds of different models on the
dozens of different hardware platforms.
And we have recipes.vm.ai
for reference guides on how to deploy
those models on the various classes of
hardware that VLM can run on. VLM is
much more than the inference engine
itself. It's ultimately a VLM project on
on GitHub where we have many other
projects part of that overall ecosystem
of inference optimization to inference
scaling and scheduling routers and
various things on top of that. So we
have VLM omni on compressor speculators.
Obviously, we're gonna go over LMD and
compressor today, but uh we we we
certainly spend a lot of time building
the overall inference ecosystem in the
open source AI space, and we're thankful
you're here to be a part of it.
So, let's get into what's new. You've
hopefully heard the buzz since early
last week on DSpark, a new speculative
decoding method published by Deepseek.
They released a paper alongside a
training code repository called deepspec
and some models on the ablations they
did. Ultimately it does it sort of falls
in line with a lot of other research in
the space. But of course as deepseek
does does a lot of engineering
excellence in making that efficient and
kind of a clear win to adopt over
existing popular methods such as
deflash. Yeah, we're we're really proud
to say that within just a few days, we
integrated support in VLM upstream. So,
you can go ahead and pull the VLM
nightly or the soon to be released
VLM0.25
and run DSpark models natively in VLM.
We've also landed in the speculators
project which is under the VLM project
for training your own speculative
decoding models. support for training
your own DSpark models ultimately in a
more efficient way than the deepspec
repo itself implements as they sort of
implement offline training that requires
generating all of your hidden states
from VL from VLM to disk to then train
your speculator offline. This takes many
many tens of terabytes of storage to
hold all those hidden states across
millions of samples. And with we can run
DLM as a live server, run speculators as
a live trainer and directly produce and
consume those hidden states in an online
training cycle. And yeah, just a tweet
here on on our announcement for this and
and some preliminary benchmarks on how
we ran the the Deepc4 Pro reference
DSpark and how it compares against the
MTP modules that were previously
natively in the in the model. We still
have more work ongoing. We are still
working on sort of the confidencebased
pruning or truncation of tokens. So kind
of having dynamic numbers of speculative
tokens in the running batch in BLM. But
yeah, we're very excited to start
training more DSpark models ourselves
and tuning their performance in BLM even
further on on more hardware platforms. I
shamelessly kind of want to plug some of
the work I've been focused on the last
week in in scaling up DSpark. I've been
pretty interested in training DSpark on
some of the latest frontier models like
GLM 5.2 and we've been posting those
models on the community. You can go
ahead and find the latest GLM 5.2 DSpark
that we've trained on the Red Hat AI
hugging phase and yeah, I've personally
learned a lot through doing this. I I
recommend training your own speculator
for especially if you have a particular
use case like a coding agent or a
writing agent and and ultimately because
of the size of training a model like GLM
5.2 to at the frontier level and and
some thankfully some great compute
donations from Verta Cloud. I was able
to get access to a GB300 cluster and
scale up this online training at over 60
GB300 GPUs roughly twothirds running VLM
producing those hidden states and
one-third running or not not exactly
that let's say half and half running the
DSpark training drafter using
speculators and shared a lot of that
with the community and yeah it's been
really fun to to do that and
particularly developing the multi-node a
capability of speculators so we can
really get this training done very
quickly with VAM speculators and Moonake
working together. Moon Cake of course
letting us communicate the hidden states
over RDMA ultimately faster fabric than
through storage and and of course
scaling for multiode. So yeah look
forward to more PRs and tuning and
speculators on yeah training these
models. Yeah Chris, it was it was Verta
Cloud. they were very very kind to fund
this this research and to open new open
models for the community. So now going
to go through some other blogs and
announcements. Yeah, just to shout out
Cohhere. They shared a fun blog on how
they manage their internal fork of BLM
that they use for their production
service and ultimately shared a lot of
particularly the AI agent skills and
workflows that they use to try and
automate the upkeep of this fork while
still getting in the latest and greatest
updates from from VLM main on upstream.
And I I think many people running BLM in
production obviously need to just manage
their own patches for for some reason if
they're if they're going to go down that
route, especially with custom models.
And I thought this was just a good peak
into how this can be done and automated
and is ultimately interesting for us as
well as as maintainers on VLM of how we
can maybe better automate some of our
day-to-day things such as cherrypicks
for releases, testing or dealing with
merge conflicts on really large changes
and branches over time. Yeah. So, pretty
interesting in the age of agents and and
open source software. Next, we have some
blogs from the VLM Omni team. They've
been pushing performance very heavily
and large scale inference on the leading
models. So, some great updates on how
they've been pushing performance and
reworking the architecture to better
support texttospech inference.
ultimately showcasing really impressive
speed ups across a variety of Texas
speech models each with their own
particular multi multimodel
architectures and doing some I think
like and overall there's these really
interesting profile graphs sort of
walking through what becomes the
bottleneck at different workload
different workloads on these various
models and how do you think about
scaling up replicas better scheduling or
or sort of like pipeline parallelism
using torch compile using cuda graphs so
ultimately really interesting deep
engineering work that's been validated
in production yeah just great to to see
the development of that project and I
mentioned there was another one and here
it's focused on an omni modality model
working with a thinker a talker and a
codeto- wave section so ultimately
taking in any sort of modality in taking
in or producing audio out and so there's
sort of three clear stages in there
between those different pieces and yeah
devel showing how they implemented
cudggraphs async chunking async output
and replica scaling for the different
parts of the pipeline that get
bottlenecked for certain workloads and
again just really interesting
engineering work I think particularly
for the future the likely future of
state-of-the-art model architectures as
these models become more you know
multimodal friendly both on the inputs
and the outputs and it becomes more of a
an expectation for these models to not
just take in text but or produce text
but to work natively in whatever
modality we want and naturally the the
form that inference takes and the
bottlenecks we have to worry about
changes greatly. So yeah I really
enjoyed reading through these yeah
engineering insights and and recommend
you read too to prepare yourself for the
future.
Next, I wanted to give a little yeah
cheeky shout out to a tweet I made last
week that I wasn't expecting to get so
much press, but I also wanted to give
respect to removing the original page
detention kernels from BLM. So obviously
I have Wuk's reply in here as well where
we're just deleting the original kernels
that were developed as part of Wuk's
research in 2023 and uh we now have much
much better kernels like flash
attention, FA3, FA4, flash infer kernels
that give us new colorless kernels or
kernels from tensor TLM generated
kernels, Triton attention, all all sorts
of different backends all that
ultimately implement the ideas of page
attention with these the flexible block
sizes and and and various other things,
prefix caching and such. Yeah, I I very
much think Wick's perspective is is is
is the right one. It's really cool to
see that we can retire this and that its
legacy will still live on regardless.
And yeah, look how far VLM has come. So
yeah, with those updates, we'll get into
the actual release and I'll kind of
hurry through because I'm taking a lot
of time. In 0.24, 24, we had a pretty
large release, more commits than usual,
571 commits from 256 contributors, 77
new ones, quite a lot for just two
weeks. Um, and uh there we landed the
Miniax M3 uh support with several
optimizations since the the the day zero
uh image we made. We've also continued
pushing performance on Deep Seek V4 and
GLM 5.2. um particularly you know any
sparse MLA we've been tuning the top K
kernel very heavily particularly for
very uh large uh context or input
sequences um and uh particularly ragged
batches uh so really key optimization
for uh agentic workloads using lots of
context um you know we've integrated new
uh you know flash infer sparse index
caching kernels um and we finally landed
support for SM120 uh for sparse MLA so
you can run deep CP4 for or GLM 5.2 on
your uh you know Blackwell RTX uh cards
and people are doing on DGX Spark uh
even if they can fit it. Um we've been
working a lot on model runner v2 um
enabling more models uh by default. So
supporting a lot of types of
quantization uh supporting common quen
and deepseek uh models running in
default there and we've ported uh
deflash spec decoding to model runner v2
with full cudigraph support on the
deflash drafter uh giving much better
performance as uh we lower the CPU
overhead uh um which is great to see. We
also landed our initial uh
implementation of dynamic speculate
decoding which is uh perfect timing uh
before uh dspark came and relies on that
infrastructure. Um this initial
implementation is relatively simple uh
but uh really important for ultimately
serving a model with speculative
decoding and now being able to scale the
the draft length of the speculator uh
all the way down to zero as you go into
higher and higher batch sizes. Um so
ultimately you're not compromising your
high throughput um uh you know portion
of your prao frontier even while you're
optimizing and maybe want to you know
speculate eight tokens or 16 tokens at
batch size one you can scale all the way
down as you go to larger more compute
heavy batch sizes. Um we landed the
streaming parser engine which is a
complete rework to how reasoning and
tool calling parsers work. Um making it
a declarative state machine instead of
just uh kind of simple uh pythonic uh
loops and and reax before. Um this is
ultimately you know we think really
critical for fixing issues with uh token
streaming that's more than one token. Uh
so obviously for spec decoding or or
diffusion models um as well as adding
parsers uh for many more models and
various bug fixes there. Uh this is the
first model with with uh with support
for diffusion Gemma the first release
with support for diffusion Gemma. Um uh
you know beyond the day zero uh uh image
we made um and uh yeah very much looking
forward to implementing more uh
diffusion large language models since
then. We added support for KV cache
watermark. So there's now a d-watermark
argument you can set to reserve some
overhead space in your free KB cache
blocks to fight against preemptions. So
if you've been seeing a lot of
preemptions in production from very long
output token decodes, take a look at the
new watermark argument. We fully
migrated to liptor torch stable AI. So
this means in future releases we will
look towards supporting multiple
versions of PyTorch on a given version
of VLM. you won't need to necessarily
pin to a single version of PyTorch which
would be huge and yeah we've changed how
we use cudable visible devices using a
much more structured device ids argument
and ultimately this is needed to make
VLM work more natively with MIG and of
course external DP load balancing at
scale yeah very quickly want to talk
really just highlight improvements on
YDP we've integrated DPP v2 on main and
DBO with Nixl
We've also a key optimization for PD is
implementing the Nixel KV push mode. So
pushing from pre-flow decode rather than
pulling improving time to first token
and in very high throughput scenarios
and we're doing a lot of work on the
Rust front end still pushing through on
par with the Python front end. On the
quantization side, we finally completed
the migration of GGUF model support to a
plug-in so we can better separate the
concerns of that support from mainline
VLM concerns. And we've dealt with many
or a few number of CVEs and security
hardening. If you're a provider looking
to upgrade, make sure you check out the
CVE that we've addressed if it might
affect your deployment and it'll be a
good reason to upgrade beyond just the
general improvements we have from
release to release. I'll stop it there
and now I'll hand it off to Charles and
and Brian for Elm Compressor.
>> Thanks, Michael. Yeah, so as we as we
mentioned, Charles and I are on the on
the model op team at Red Hat. So we're
part of the team that maintains
speculators as well as LM compressor and
compressed tensors, which is kind of a
backend for for saving these compressed
models. So today we just want to run you
through very quickly some of the updates
we've made in the latest versions of LM
Compressor. I follow the same format
that Michael had. So 200 commits, 66
contributors, 32 new contributors. So I
think we're I think we not certainly not
the scale of VLM, but we're getting good
contraction and good community
involvement, which we love to see as
well. We're starting starting with more
on the new model support. So we're doing
more than just publishing models. We're
building software here, but a lot of the
stuff we've done in Q2 and really in the
whole quarter or the whole year is to
improve our support of large models of
new models and and reducing the time
delay between like zero day release to
when we publish on the Redhead AI or
space. So as you can see Quen, Gemma 4,
Kim K26, Steepseek, GLM, lots of really
big models, lots of models that are
released in their own quantization
format. So a lot of things that we've
had to do in terms of the new features
to kind of enable that and and speed up
the the time between that turnover. So
what that's yielded in terms of V.11 and
V.0.12
are the new features to the right. So
I'll let Charles kind of go through some
of some of the new features and then
circle back on some of the like road
road mapap ahead. So let me pass to
Charles.
>> Yeah, thanks. The DDP and multiGPU
support as well converter entry point
we're going to talk about in dedicated
slides. So I'll go ahead and talk about
the the ones at the end first. So
version 12 was pretty much just a
transformers v5 release. There was a lot
of stuff that had to go on under the
hood to continue to support
transformers. The way they handle is
very different in practice for users.
Not a not a lot of changes. There's a
new API to enable loading thee modules
faster and thee models. But yeah, these
two are pretty much all under the hood.
There's a massive set of refactors that
are enabling a lot of these model
support and and things. to the left did
refactors for the observers, the life
cycle, micros scale formats, and then as
far as usability, AWQ is now
transformed, so you can compose it with
GBDQ, which is allows us to unlock some
new better accuracy values. As far as
the DDP multiGPU support though, version
11 had a we enabled this for a ton of
different flows, long running things
like AWQ that can take 8 to 10 hours for
large models. you can linearly pretty
much speed it up based on the number of
GPUs you have available with the TDP
support and in version 12 we released
model free PTQ multiGPU support. So
that's also available to to use. So as
you can see here the memory usage goes
way down the speed goes way up and this
continues to beyond just the four we
tested with eight or however many you
have access to.
Yeah. So back to Brian.
>> Thanks Rose. Yeah. So, and just wanted
to end on the other bullet point we had
in the new features. Basically, what
we're calling a converter entry point,
converter abstraction. So, this has kind
of evolved over the course of really I
think about a year when we were first
looking at model free PTQ. The idea here
is to to operate on a model checkpoint
and create something new without
necessarily having to load it up as a
hugging face model or in VLM so that it
can be a little bit quicker for for for
more naive compression algorithms or as
as I'll show like some some new things
that came up along the way as we as we
tried to improve our support for these
new models. So what started as model
free PTQ is is really just operating at
the safe tensor level to apply some
quantization scheme in a round to
nearest kind of data free scheme. So
like not using GPTQ or AWQ but still
being able to kind of rapid prototype on
these things. We had set up some code
for that. We found that there's a lot of
overlap with some of the things we
wanted to do in terms of like converting
a checkpoint. So if a checkpoint is in
some old format like auto AWQ or FP
quant or in a newer format that we want
to convert to compressed tensors so that
we can own the loadup cycle or do
anything else to it further downstream
that we have this abstraction that kind
of allows us to create new instances for
each of these cases. So each of these
links in the slides will point to an
example or to a PR that's that's doing
these and in addition to that from
conversion also to dequantization as I
mentioned before a lot of the models are
published in quantized formats I've
linked those down below in order for us
to do anything downstream of that in
order to change the quantization format
we kind of have a separation of concerns
through LM compressor through the
oneshot pathway that everything that
goes in there is already dequantized or
full precision So we don't have to worry
about that. So this dequantization piece
is what allows us to kind of do that as
a pre-processing beforehand before
hitting the um compressor flow. I think
we're pretty happy with the robustness
of this. We're able to whip up new new
converters pretty quickly. A lot of
these like we had struggled with autowq
conversion scripts with community users,
but having them code to a given contract
had made that a lot simpler. It's not
rocket science, but I think it's a nice
abstraction and and I think we're at a
point where we're willing to kind of
broadcast this to the community. If
people are doing a lot of checkpoint
level modification, a lot of things
could fit in this pattern. So, please
let us know if that's the case. Coming
soon into in the next version, we want
to kind of extend this what we have with
model free PTQ with what we're calling
model free Higs. The idea there is an
automated selection of the mixed
precision quantization config that that
you want according to a given budget for
for weights and the accuracy goals that
you have. So this came out of our
collaborator research group like the
white paper there as well. But that's
kind of one of the directions we want to
extend this in the near future. Yeah.
And and if you have yeah for this or any
other features or or questions you might
have feel free to reach out raising an
issue on our on our repos or there's
also a dedicated LM compressor Slack
channel that I've linked below. Thanks
for the time.
>> Awesome. Thanks a bunch guys. That's a
great update. So yeah, let's go ahead
and hand it off to Rob for the the big
update on LMD.
>> Yep. Thanks guys. So first I just wanted
to talk a little bit about what LMD is
and and why it's needed. So while VM
does a really great job of optimizing
performance on a single node, LMD
focuses on optimizations that could
exist as you start to scale out a
deployment. So there's multiple
different ways people can deploy BLM but
one of the most common ways is on
Kubernetes which is a way to scale many
many different applications and for most
applications and what a lot of people
get started with for for inference is
the following pattern. You'll create a
deployment resource which will create
multiple replica pods of VLM and then a
service will sit in front of that
deployment and requests are roundroined
between the different VLM pods. This is
a pretty simple deployment pattern and
one that we usually see folks getting
started with. But the problem with this
is that LLM requests don't look very
similar to traditional HTTP requests. If
you think about an agentic application,
you can have requests with hundreds of
thousands of input tokens that take tens
of seconds to process. They're heavily
heavily multi-turn where if you're an
agent and you're working in a harness,
you're going to generate some text to
reason, call a tool, send the result
back to the model, so on and so forth
over and over and over again. And we
have these two distinct phases of
inference, the prefill and the decode
phase, which could potentially run on on
different GPUs. And so LMD's job is to
really be aware of the fact that it's
running an inference request as opposed
to a generic HTTP request and attempt to
implement different distributed
optimizations that can outperform the
kind of naive deployment service pattern
that you see most people getting started
with. So, LMD is a distributed
inferencing framework that seeks to
optimize a whole cluster of VLM pods
and LMD does this on top of Kubernetes.
We have lots of great users between
enterprises to clouds to model companies
to frontier to to folks running model as
a service. And you can take a look at
some of the adopters and some of the
blogs we have on on different features.
But stepping way back, I wanted to talk
through a couple of the different
examples of features that LMD has which
can help to optimize performance. And
I'm going to go through five different
ones here.
The first and most important
optimization that LMD can do is to have
prefix smart routing during the an
inference request. And so I have a basic
architecture design here which explains
how it how it works. But basically a pod
gets deployed onto the cluster that has
a proxy and something called the
endpoint picker. And these all make up
what we collectively call the LMD
router. And so when a client request
comes in to this router, the EP contains
all of the special LLM serving logic.
And most importantly, one optimization
is And most importantly, one
optimization is prefix cache awareness.
This can give by far the most bang for
the buck of any optimization we have in
LLMD. And in particular, the main thing
that it does is allows requests to be
routed to the VLM pod that has the
prefix already cached. And this is
extremely important for agentic
workloads which have this heavily
heavily heavily multi-turn pattern where
potentially one single inference session
can send the same context back to the
model over and over and over again. And
VLM obviously at this point has really
robust support for prefix caching. And
so the EP keeps track of the state of
the various BLM pods and routes requests
to the pod that's going to get a prefix
cache hit. And this can have orders of
magnitude better performance than naive
load balancing where if you have a
scaleout deployment of 20 pods, you're
only going to have a one over 20 chance
of getting a prefix cache hit if you're
randomly or roundroin selecting pods.
And so this is really the first key
optimization that we have in LMD is this
prefix cache aware routing. Importantly
however prefix affinity is not the only
metric to look at. We also want to deal
with back pressure where if certain pods
are overloaded because they're dealing
with really really long requests, we
want to instead route the request to
other pods. And so LMD has a library of
scrapers, scorers, filters. It's very
configurable and can add some pretty
sophisticated scoring logic on top of
the pods. And we also have a more
advanced mode where actually an an XG
boost model is trained online and this
model makes predictions about which pod
is going to get the best latency. And
this is a really good feature that is
used by some advanced deployments of of
LMD. This is really the first key
feature is the prefix cache and
intelligent load balancing in the
design.
Beyond this, the EP and LMD and VLM have
worked very very closely together to
offer a KV cache management.
So, as I kind of mentioned before, the
KV cache and prefix cache hit rates are
an extremely important optimization to
maintain. And inside of VLM, KV caches
are held in in CP GPU RAM in a least
recently used structure. And so after a
period of time, if requests have not
come back to the to the server, we'll
end up with we'll end up with prefix
cache misses. And you might be familiar
on various instances, various service
providers that they offer a cache TTL
where they maintain your tokens for some
period of time, maybe five minutes, an
hour, etc. And so VLM offers an
offloading connector or and some others
from IBM research have contributed this
to VLM which offloads KV caches to CPU
memory. And recently we've added in a
tiering structure where this the KVS can
be pushed from CPU memory into various
storage systems both local NVMe or
remote network file systems like Seph or
Luster and so on and so forth. And then
the EP needs to be aware of this. So we
support tiered prefix cache affinity in
the EP which allows us to route requests
to pods and try to land them on the ones
that have the KVS in the GPU memory and
then if not in the CPU memory and so on
and so forth. So this kind of KV cache
management is a really critical
deployment pattern that's useful for
expanding the pool of KV cache size and
increasing the time that KV caches
remain in the memory such that we can
avoid recomputing.
Another example feature that we offer in
LLMD is something called pre-filled
decode disagregation. This has been a
very hot topic in the open source
ecosystem for a while. But what pre-fill
decode disagregation does is it
separates the prefill and decode phases
of inference into two separate replicas.
So we'll have a prefill worker and a
decode worker. The EP is aware of
whether BLM is configured in PD
disagregation mode. But what's very very
nice is we have a very composable
situation. So when selecting which
prefill worker, we can use all the same
logic of prefix cache affinity to select
the proper prefill worker and the proper
decode worker.
And very importantly, the KV transfer
where we move the KV cache from the
prefill pod to the decode pod after we
process the prefill happens over
accelerated networking. So we've been
using we we've been in BLM supporting a
couple of different transfer engines.
The one that we focus on the most in LMD
comes from NVIDIA Dynamo with Nixl which
supports multiple different transport
options but in particular UCX which
pulls the KV caches over the Infiniband
networking. It's definitely a bit
challenging to get these accelerated
networks um uh working uh on some
clouds. uh but uh at this point uh PD
has been deployed in many of uh VLM and
LMD's largest users uh which you know
really really helps uh to improve
quality of service by um allowing the
prefill work to not interrupt the decode
work
and then beyond this as we think about
large models like GLM um you know where
they might not even fit within a single
node or where we want to increase the KV
cache size as much as possible
Um, LMD supports wide expert parallelism
where each replica where a single
logical instance of VLM is spread over
multiple pods. Um, we use an API um in
uh Kubernetes called leader worker set
uh which allows us to co-chedu multiple
pods together. Um and these pods are uh
part of the same um PyTorch process
group uh which allows um you know uh
attention to run independently um and
then the expert layer to run um um as
part of a single forward pass. This
composes naturally with uh the
pre-filled decode disagregation that we
have and I'm going to cover this in a
bit more detail in a second when I talk
about uh you know serving serving GLM.
Um this is another really important
feature uh that allows us to uh serve
the largest models uh over multiple
nodes.
Beyond this, LMD also includes features
for uh uh dealing with fairness and
priority. Um I've noticed recently uh
some cloud service providers um offer
things like provision throughput or
different quality of service tiers like
premium, standard, and fast. Um and the
EP includes capabilities that enable you
to um build something like this. Um in
particular, there's a saturation
detector uh which can be configured to
determine uh you know when the VLM pods
are oversaturated and then requests will
start to cue in the EP. We call this
feature flow control. And what this
enables is for you to offer different
quality of service to different users.
So maybe you have a customerf facing
application tenant B and a developer you
know internal developer application
called tenant A in a period of time
where or paid and unpaid users for
instance and in a period of time where
there's a lot of load we can choose to
process the high priority requests
before the low priority requests and so
the EP's flow control feature implements
this saturation detector where we'll
start to cue requests as the traffic
increases and then we'll dispatch
requests in order of priority. So this
is a really really cool feature that can
be used to enable these quality of
service and or things like provisioned
throughput that a lot of service
providers want to offer to their
customers. And beyond this there's also
batch capabilities in LMD which composes
very nicely with the intelligent request
queuing. So a very common pattern that
we'll see is that users will have online
use cases and offline use cases such as
batch jobs which are often either
background agents or things like
evaluation jobs or reinforcement
learning jobs. And in LMD we have a
component called the LMD async processor
which basically is a stateful component
that will dispatch requests. It will
talk to the EP and probe the EP for
saturation detection and then dispatch
requests. The EP treats these as low
priority requests such that if there's
online traffic, they will be prioritized
over the offline traffic. But this
allows you to make progress on the
offline batch workload without starving
the online requests. So we have some
users who run shared endpoints that
serve production traffic and then
they're able to put batch workloads onto
that same running instance without
having the batch workload completely
draining the completely oversaturating
the online workloads. So this is a
really nice feature a nice application
of flow control into the system. That's
the overall these are some examples of
features we have in LMD. There's some
other interesting stuff related to
autoscaling. We have some collaborations
and are adopting things like Dynamo's
model express for start for fast
startup. But these hit on some of the
key optimizations that we have in the
project which are all focused on how to
serve inference as efficiently as
possible. So a great application of this
is for serving agentic workloads. And so
I think Cam's on the call, but Semi
analysis has done a nice job of creating
an agentic benchmark called agent X,
which is a cloud code traces. So it
simulates what it's like to run a
service that's backing cloud code. These
workloads are agentic. And so what this
is characterized by is having very very
very high multi-turn. So you'll see the
same context being sent to the model
over and over and over again. And also
these requests are very long. So a lot
of times you'll see benchmarks with a
thousand input sequence, a thousand
output tokens or even or or even 8,000.
In comparison to long context serving
and 8,000 input sequence requests is
just actually not that long. The
requests in a cloud code trace can
easily average a 100,000 input tokens.
And so a lot of the features that we
have in LMD such as prefix affinity such
as YDP are really really useful for
serving this type of agentic workload.
And the first and so I'm going to talk
about how to serve GLM 5.2 which is
obviously one of the one of the coolest
models today on H200's
using LMD an example. And just for some
context, why do we need YDP for serving
these large models? The first is that
reason is that tensor parallelism, which
is the way that we typically deploy the
llama style dense models, works great
for single node, but doesn't scale to
multi-node. And so every layer when you
deploy with tensor parallelism uses a
column parallel matrix, a row parallel
matrix, and an all reduce. And we do
this in the MLP, and we do this in self
attention. And so twice per layer we
have an all reduce. And this all reduce
is very very bandwidth intensive because
every rank is talking to every other
rank. They're all exchanging all the
same information
with each other. And so this is not
going to scale to multi-node where we we
we are going to be sending the data over
the network as opposed to over the NV
links in the GPUs. Additionally, when we
deploy with tensor parallelism, the MLA
style models have a huge issue. When we
look at llama style models, the GQA
attention, they have KV heads and
there's actually eight KV heads. And the
reason for this is that the KV heads are
the dimension that you can shard the KV
cache on. When we compare this to and so
the KV head zero goes on rank zero, KV
head one goes on rank one, so on and so
forth. When we look at MLA models,
there's a single latent compressed KV
vector. And so there's actually no
dimension to shard this on. And so when
you deploy a model like GLM or a model
like DeepSeek with tensor parallelism,
we actually will have eight copies of
the same vector. Obviously dramatically
reducing the number of KV blocks that we
can fit these massive requests into. And
so the way to deploy and get around
these problems and if you remember the
original deepseek design is using
something called DP attention EPOE data
parallel attention runs basically a
single logical instance of VLM on every
rank. It manages the KV memory and then
we do a dispatch operation after thee
router which which let's say rank zero
got routed to expert 2 and expert 4. we
do this sparse alt all which sends the
request to rank one and rank three and
so this is a sparse operation meaning
we're only sending a small amount of
data and so these dispatch combine
operations can scale well to multi-node
whereas the all reduces cannot and so
this design where we have DP attention
allows us to only have one copy of the
KV vector for every token so we get much
much more effective KV usage per token.
And because we're able to scale this
over multi-node, we have only one copy
of the experts over the whole logical
replica, meaning all the rest of the RAM
can be allocated to KB caches. And so
this is a really useful setup for
dealing with agentic use cases because
when we have a model like GLM the where
it's 700 billion parameters or so we're
going to consume 700
gigabytes of RAM that leaves only very
very small space for KB caches even on
an H200. And so to fit this model and to
effectively utilize it we need to make
sure we have enough KB cache space to
hold all that GPU RAM. And by deploying
with YDP, we get both of these things.
And so in this setup that I'm going to
show, we have the following situation.
We have one decode replica which is
spread across two pods. So if we see I I
just catted out the the current state of
the cluster. So we have one decode
replica which is expert parallel 16. So
it's a single instance of BLM deployed
over multiple nodes. So there's one pod
on node one on node two and then there's
a leader worker set which co-chedules
these together and then we have two
replicas of EP16 prefill.
The astute reader or the astute listener
will notice that it's very very
important because we're running with DP
attention that we route requests to the
proper DP rank for KV cache affinity.
And so this is actually something that
we support in the EP where the EP can
target a specific DP rank. This is
called DPaware scheduling. And so we
deploy the VLM pods. It creates eight
API servers per pod. Each API server
targets hits a specific GPU. And the EP
can then route requests specifically to
a rank that has the KB cache. And so
then what we see is we look at some of
the data. What we can see is that this
is really really important. The top
chart you can see the the KV cache hit
rate and we can see that for these
multi-turn workloads we're able to hit
90 plus% prefix cache reuse. So in this
agentic workload there's really really
really really high reuse. So in in this
this middle row here is the throughput
per this is on H200's on this is on
H200's. This is on H200's with NVL link
in between the nodes within a node and
infinibands between and this was on core
kubernetes and so what we see is that
the vast majority of the tokens are
cached and so this kind of prefix
awareness is really really really
important and we're able to kind of keep
the TTF pretty low under under 3 second
median. Then the other point to make is
and I I think the Sammy analysis guys
have done a great job of showing off the
trade-off between interactivity and
throughput. But one very important thing
to be aware of is that as you increase
concurrency, so as you increase the
number of concurrent requests on the
GPU, you will see an more throughput.
So you can get more tokens out of your
GPU, but the latency per user will go
down. So like in this case we can see
that for DeepSeek V4 Pro, I think this
is on a B300,
if you're targeting a latency of 50
tokens per second per user, you'll be
able to get around 2,000 tokens per
second per GPU. So you'll need versus if
you target latency of 25 tokens per
second per user, you'll maybe will get
something like 4,000 tokens per second
per I should be you'll maybe get
per GPU. And so you can see this very
clearly in the agent X traces. So I ran
these bumps are basically different runs
with different amounts of concurrency.
So we have 25 50 concurrent 100
concurrent 150 concurrent 200 concurrent
and what we can see is that the output
tokens per second per GPU. So this is
the this is the the y-axis the
throughput as we increase concurrency we
get more tokens per second and for lat
as we increase concurrency we latency
drops. So we go from 75 tokens per
second per user down to like down to
like 50 tokens per second per user as
the concurrency increases.
And so I just for comparison I I went on
to open router and they have some really
great stats about what latency various
providers have. And so for instance for
Z.AI running this same GLM 5.2 model
they're getting about 50 output tokens
per second per user on open router. and
it costs $4.40
per million tokens on this setup. We at
50 tokens per second per user. So let's
say this is like 55, we're getting
around 400 tokens per second per GPU.
And so what we can basically see is that
if we get 400 output tokens per second
per GPU at 50 output tokens per second
per user. And if we assume that the GPU
costs $3 per hour or so on reserve
pricing, this effectively translates to
around $2 per million output tokens. So
this overall LMD VLM stack is cheaper to
run than consuming a shared endpoint.
Obviously, it's not quite a fair
comparison because this is at 100%
utilization and so on and so forth. But
I wanted to make the point that just
with this open source stack of the LLM,
LLMD running this agentic workload, you
can be pretty competitive and with
reasonable assumptions for the GPU
pricing, this is what a kind of one year
to threeyear reservation costs. You you
can build a system that's pretty
competitive with where the market is
kind of serving these these models
today. Yeah, that's kind of what I had
to say. And and all of these
optimizations are critical, right? Like
if you don't have prefix cache
awareness, it doesn't work. Like you're
going to spend all your time recmputing
the prompts. If you don't have PD, you
can't deploy with YDP. If you don't have
YDP, you don't have enough KD cache
space to fit all these requests. And so
all of these optimizations stack up to
make it possible to serve the hardest
possible workload which is these really
really long context agentic traces for a
big model on H200s. So this is kind of
what I wanted to show is how all these
different optimizations layer on to
enable a system that's competitive with
where Frontier model servers are are at
today. So thank you all very much. I
know I probably went a little bit long,
but I I appreciate everyone listening.
>> No. Yeah, we're at perfect uh perfect
time basically. Rob, I was wondering if
you would cover one more slide right
after this.
>> Yeah, we also have added LMD to to
Inference X. So Ezra has done a great
job of delivering our first submission
and then we're very excited about agent
X and how it can show off all these
different features from prefix awareness
to YDP to things like KD offloading
which isn't really too much explored in
in the current setup that I showed. So
yeah, we love semi analysis and take
take yeah take a take a look at our
submissions.
>> Yeah, thanks a lot. There there were
some interesting questions in the chat
we can maybe go through first. Yeah.
Bala do you want to say like which
hardware you were asking about like yeah
I I mean like the GPUs were involved on
had had Envy link between them if on
single node but for multi-node like PD
they had infinitive not like Nvink.
>> Okay.
>> No no makes sense. Yeah, I got I think
Sha Robert answered it during while his
presentation too. So all good. Yeah.
Thanks.
>> Okay. Yeah. Any other questions people
want to ask you or I
>> I had one more question. I think it's
it's from an outsider point of view,
right? Like wheelm production stack and
LLMD like how we should see it because
there is some overlapping functionality.
Yeah. So I'm trying to understand how we
combine them or how do we consume it?
I think that so I I I personally don't
know too much about production stack. I
so I I don't really know how to I think
of them like they're solving a similar a
similar problem. So I I think it's
probably more of an eitheror versus uh
use them together. So So yeah, I don't I
don't but I do think that production
stack supports like the gateway API
inference extension. So, like the one
thing I wanted to mention is so this
like this this like the way that this
all worked is I I I kind of glossed over
this, but like technically the way that
this works is there's an API called an
inference pool which is kind of like
similar to a Kubernetes service in the
sense of like you discover pods through
Kubernetes labels and then there's
something called the gateway API
inference extension which is which is
basically how the inference pool gets
connected to the EP. P and so and then
that allows you to hook the EP up to
various Kubernetes gateways and so if if
production stack supports the concept of
inference extension then it's possible
that some of the functionality in LMD
could be could be used
>> intersect it yeah and one more I think
we're running out of time one last
question I think LMD I heard you say it
supports gang scheduling such a way that
if there is no like if you have to
deploy this and X number of prefill that
can decode if all of that is not
available it's not going to launch it
right is that implemented yeah
>> so the so
LMD project doesn't doesn't include it
doesn't include deployment APIs so like
in the examples like you can you can
deploy with a it's agnostic to like how
the servers are deployed in a lot of our
examples we have just using deployments
to to do that for instance, but you
could deploy with something like Nvidia
Grove.
>> Yes, that's what Okay. So, I would it's
not implemented in this. Okay, perfect.
All right.
>> Yeah, it's it's it's not like we don't
have a like LMD as a project is
unopinionated about how you deploy the
servers. It's kind of like and and so
what this means is we can compose the
project with all sorts of other ways to
deploy. I like leader worker set which
is useful for like very homogeneous
clusters. Grove is really going to be
useful for like clusters especially
GB200
uh GB200 GB300 where maybe you have some
topology awareness. There's other sorts
of schedulers out there. All of those
can work with work with BLM. But one one
thing I would mention is like for some
like more complicated flows. So for
instance for like PD disagregation you
want to be careful about how this like
some of the operational flows about like
how to roll out a new version where you
don't want to select pod A and pod B
with different versions of BLM. We've
worked with some folks in the community
to develop this thing called the
disagregated set operator which is
intended to kind of solve this problem.
So this is built into leader worker set
for instance. So I wouldn't say that
like we have a a hard deployment API but
like we do work with other communities
to try to like develop develop give
requirements that can can help to
achieve things like what you're talking
about.
>> Okay. Super awesome. This is very
useful. Thank you so much. Thank you.
>> Awesome. Great questions. Well, yeah, we
are unfortunately over time. Thanks a
lot to to Rob, Ryan, and Charles for
yeah, stepping in and giving us a great
update on the various related projects
to VLM. As always, thanks for being a
part of the community. We'd love for you
to continue being part of the community
in a in a even greater capacity if you
can. Contributions are always welcome.
Join the VLM Slack if you have any
questions or want to get involved in
stuff. Yeah, there's lots of learning
resources and yeah, the power of the
community is is what makes open source
software good, successful, and
ultimately rises all all rising tide
raises all boats. And yeah, that's all
we have for you this week. We'll get to
you in the in two weeks with a deep dive
in Prime RL. And yeah, hope to see you
then. Hope you have a good two weeks.
Take care, everyone.
Bye-bye.